[Music]
foreign
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive and it's time to see
what's making the headlines with the
Belfast Telegraph columnist Alison
Morris and a former former conservative
MP advisor and advisor to the Royal
household who's now chief executive of
the charity business in the community
Mary McLeod they'll be with us from now
until just before midnight so let's see
what's on some of those front pages
we've received quite a few uh already
and
we'll just show you the front page of
the telegraph first which is quite
striking today it says there are
concerns dissident Republicans may be
plotting attacks to coincide with Rishi
sunak and Joe Biden's visit to Northern
Ireland next week
the mail reflects on King Charles's
backing for Research into links between
the monarchy and slavery the headline
Royals hit by new payout demands over
slavery links
the express speaks to Ukraine's
ambassador to the UK who says his
government has no intention of
negotiating with the Putin regime
the sun is dismayed at the prospect of
travel tomorrow their headline bad
Friday
meanwhile the times leads with the
latest on strikes as up to half of
doctors in England will be absent next
week
and according to the star Italian
politicians want to banish English words
like deadline from their countries
dialect
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch us
but let's speak now to Alison Morris and
Mary McLeod who are here to review some
of the front pages that have dropped
already great to see you both thanks for
joining us uh tonight Mary let's start
with you if I may the front page of the
Daily Telegraph really caught my eye uh
tonight not least for that dramatic
image from Paris but also their main
story that there is a terror threat
ahead of Joe Biden's visit to Northern
Ireland for the anniversary of the Good
Friday agreement tell us more
yes and this is such a worrying story
and you know this the Good Friday
agreement was such an important point in
the history Northern Ireland because it
stopped 30 years of conflict
um and it'll be very real to to Allison
but this is you know I 1995 I went over
and did some work with the Northern
Ireland peace process saying and you
still see some of that fragility in in
the communities in Northern Ireland and
and it was so incredible when a that
Good Friday agreement was put in place
and and some peace was seen and now to
get another story of where some of that
peace is threatened so you know it's
whether something will happen but they
say they have intelligence that these
terrorist attacks will be on police
officers and and they will be targeted
is massively worrying and especially
when Joe Biden and of course are going
over there but I just feel for the for
people in Northern Ireland because they
have been through so much over so many
decades and even just the threat of more
outbreaks of violence
um just as enough to destroy local
communities who've worked so hard to
rebuild
uh yeah Alison I thought from you on
this certainly you know it's very
sobering uh 25 years uh since a good
Friday agreement and now this threat to
possible attacks on the anniversary and
it's and it's said here in the Daily
Telegraph which I didn't realize it's
the biggest police operation for a
decade in Northern Ireland
yeah I mean this came from the monthly
meeting of the Northern Ireland police
and board which took place today and I
thought the assistant chief Constable
said that they had Community
intelligence that had a period which is
due to take place in Derry on Monday so
this weekend Easter weekend is the
traditional time when Republican marches
take place it's a commemoration of the
anniversary of the 1916 Easter raisin
and for the past few years distant
Republicans have held a period in Dairy
um that has resulted in violence and
clashes with police what they said was
that they had intelligence that they
were going to use young people to lure
police in and have in terms of having
clashes with the police and once police
then moved into the area that they had
intelligence that there was going to be
an attack launched on them this
particular is on Monday and we know
Baden is a raven on Tuesday his his
visitor to Northern Ireland is quite
brief he's coming for um a stopover on
the Tuesday evening and then he's cut
short his events in Northern Ireland and
like last month the terror threat in
Northern Ireland was increased and had
only been it had only been done greater
the year before and that was because of
an attack and attempted murder of a
police officer whether that had any burn
in the main administration's decision to
cut short his visit to Northern Ireland
because he will be here for a very short
period of time he's visiting a new
University campus and he's off after
that across the border and we have been
told he was born to go to stormland
which is the the seat of devolve power
in Northern Ireland and speak to the
assembly members there none of that's
happened and I we had heard at one stage
it was going to unveil a bus to George
Mitchell on American Envoy who helped so
much with the peace process that's not
happening now so the security situation
I think is probably fair in to those
plans being cut short and that visit
being cut short I mean Biden is a friend
the Ireland is he's proud of his Irish
Roots it would be you know a bit of an
old goal for distant Republicans to
launch an attack around same visit but
remember with an American president
almost all that sort of Razzmatazz that
comes with a presidential visit also
comes the word is press and these are a
very very small group of people the
majority of Northern Ireland is a very
peaceful place now to live a very
different place to live but for them
there's a massive propaganda value even
imagine and launching even the smallest
of attack at a time when they know the
the eyes of the world are watching and a
lot of what they do is about propaganda
because they know that these sort of
sporadic attacks are going to make any
difference to our sort of constitutional
situation or the political situation
here so they do use them for propaganda
but what this is the sort of annual
occurrence around this parade that take
place in Dairy and the thing that I find
saddest about it is that this very young
man involved in those strict
disturbances people who were born long
after the Good Friday agreement there's
much to be celebrated in 25 years but
we're also speaking about very young men
people 17 18 years of age who born after
that who really shouldn't be involved in
this kind of activity Alison I'm gonna
have to jump in because we want to get
through a few more papers if we can
we're so fortunate to have your Insight
from Belfast on this uh tonight we're
also very fortunate to have Mary's
Insight uh in the royal family having
worked for the Royal household uh front
page of the daily mail tomorrow
reporting uh that the Royals are hit by
new payout demands over slavery links it
seems like it's going to be some
uncomfortable uh stories for print for
King Charles
well the pilots of course have said that
the king takes this issue profoundly
seriously and supports this study that
has been done into the sort of the royal
family and slavery links as the
University of Manchester with historic
Royal palaces and and we've heard
comments in recent years from whether
it's the king or the Prince of Wales who
have both previously expressed real
distress and personal sorrow at the
suffering limb with the slave trade and
you know Prince William said when he was
in Jamaica that it was abhorrent and
should never have happened
um and the king is absolutely determined
to to do something
um about it so um it is interesting and
I think what people don't perhaps
realize um with with this is the work
that the King has done and for
encouraging work on Race for over 20
years I mean it's in business in the
community it's the longest standing
campaign there is equality campaign and
it was set up by the king in 1995 to
address the inequalities in black Asian
and mixed race and ethnically diverse
employees in the workplaces around the
UK and in 2018 launched the recent work
Charter
um so a seven step commitment to for
employee lawyers to can really reduce
inequalities in in the workplace
um and today there are nearly a thousand
symmetries which represent 6.2 million
employees so he's been behind so much
for many years of trying to do something
about race and of course this is also if
we look at we can look backwards and
look back to whether it's the 15th
century and look at the implications of
that but the whole society then as well
were just I mean there was horrific
inequalities and
um and racism in across society and
across countries then
um but we should also be looking forward
at the the the issues that are still
with human trafficking and it's still
the slave trade in essence with human
trafficking is still in society today
yeah but of course the the King was it
it was Monday Thursday and he was at
York so it's of course that didn't get
as much coverage but just supporting and
all these people who do masses and
volunteering which is what he wants to
do linked to the coronation with a big
help out
um on Monday the 8th of May so if we can
all get behind that volunteering that
and we can all do as part of Monday
Thursday that would be brilliant and I'm
just a sales for speaking to Salesforce
today you know they're doing 1.1 million
volunteering days so that's all everyone
volunteer thanks Mary I'm gonna have to
jump in Alison a thought from you on
this it's also on the front page of uh
The Daily Telegraph tomorrow and as Mary
was saying there you know King Charles
is really trying to tackle some of these
very difficult issues in Royal history
but he's also seeing protests on various
walkabouts and visits that he's doing in
a way that the queen never did
yeah because it's going to be a very
different kind of monarchy and what he
has done and if you read those stories
as you see he's allowed this research
group access to the Royal archives
because King Charles has clearly decided
that to try and hide any of these
ancient archives to try and cover them
up to try in any way deny that the royal
family at that time had links to the
slave tree of the royal African company
would just be foolish it would prolong
it instead there seems to have been a
decision and he's a he's a monarch that
doesn't seem to be afraid to get
involved in in politics in the way maybe
the queen would have is to open the
doors do you open the books to let this
research be looked at and then to face
it head on and face the the difficult
um questions that comes after that but I
mean having this all documented
historically I think is just so
important anyway I mean I'm journalists
I would say that you know words are
incredibly important but then actions
are as well so this is a very different
type of monarchy it's you know King
Charles has very strong views himself he
doesn't seem to be afraid they express
them to allow the um the public as a is
if your live researchers you'll learn
that research into the public access to
those URL archives I think it's quite
refreshing you know those are things
that are probably still hidden for many
many hundreds of years and now they're
going to be open to the public to look
through and see exactly what happened
and it'll make for a very difficult
reading but at the same time too maybe
this is the time this is the ERA this is
the generation and which we face what
happened head on and and Mary just a
brief thought from you if I may before
uh we uh rap you know the front page of
the Morning Star is also talking about
uh the protests uh that King Charles saw
in York your take having worked in the
Royal household about how things may be
changing
well I think there'll always be a few
people who want to protest and in in in
Britain we you know we allow that and
people have a right to say what they
think and I mean the the country is
still very Pro monarchy but
um there will be people who will Who
will speak out against but and then it's
a shame for Monday Thursday because I
think it did take away from that
volunteering story a bit in terms of
headlines which is the whole point of on
Monday Thursday celebrating all those
incredible Local Heroes and people the
unsung heroes of our local communities
who do so much but
um the there's certainly I mean the King
has never been someone to shirk away
from the reality of what's going on and
he was talking about environment and
conservation when no one else was and
and it was similar to to race so
um he will absolutely keep on doing what
he believes in and and fighting on
behalf of those people who really need
support
okay Mary Allison thanks very much we're
going to take a quick break uh we'll
have more of the press preview after
this short break including Kate Forbes
who lost the SMP leadership election she
wants it to be re-run we'll talk about
why when we come back
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview here on Sky News and with me
this evening to review tomorrow's
newspapers is Alison Morris and Mary
McLeod they are continuing uh to drop
let's go back to you Alison if I may uh
you've picked out a story also on the
front page of the Daily Telegraph uh
tomorrow that Kate Forbes who have
caused lost to Hamza Yousaf uh in the
leadership contest in Scotland is now
calling for a rerun following uh
revelations in recent days tell us more
yeah well I mean they're reporting that
supporters of Kit Forbes are saying that
but we all know what that means we all
know means that she is quite like a
rerun of it and we know because of those
very dramatic scenes over the last few
days and police are still camped outside
necklace sturgeon's house despite the
fact that um that we know that her
husband Peter Merle has been in release
of the police are still investigating
there's still detectives at our home and
all of this is obviously overshadowed
the the SMP leadership contest care
Forbes I think um believes that given
the absolutely horrendous publicity of
the past few days she has a chance if
she has a another go with it um at the
leadership challenge she was as at one
point as we all know she was the the
favorite and then suffered herself from
some quite poor publicity in the run-off
to that
um it is interesting that she wants to
put herself through that again for a
second go on but I do think of the SMP
in general that this has been such a
damage in week for them in terms of
publicity and there's going to be have
to be a lot of Souls searching whether
that means going back again for another
later but I'm not sure that even that's
going to solve what's going on at the
minute I think it needs a complete
checkup and it won't be a tell us
investigations over that there'll be
able to leave and start to rebuild
properly the the reputation within the
party and obviously with the the
Scottish public yeah and I should say
Peter Murrell and and Nicola sturgeon
won't comment on a live police
investigation but it certainly hasn't
been a great couple of days for them
Mary a brief thought from you uh is it
realistic at all Kate forbes's request
that the leadership contest is Rerun
well for her I guess it's worth a tried
it wasn't very close contest and
therefore
um it's it's definitely worth seeing if
she can get something from it and but
you know we would remember of course
that Peter Marvel was was released
without charge and we can't comment on a
live investigation but a base for having
the Youssef the new first minister in
Scotland he has his work cut out for
himself in terms of governance because
this is about handling of donations and
then of course police have been involved
so he definitely has a lot of work to do
just to regain some sort of reputation
in Scotland and in how they govern yeah
Alison a quick thought from you on the
front page of the sun it's not going to
be news that many of you will want to
see tonight I'm afraid but they are
forecasting terrible travel tomorrow
you know as a journalist if you're stuck
for a front page over the Easter
holidays
I mean really it's um we could have took
this from it every every Easter holiday
and bank holiday for the past 10 years
and just changed it change the date on
it we all know if you want to go away on
the Easter break leave early yeah Mary
thought from you on that it's not
looking great is it
it's not I think I just say stay at home
and there'll be lots of things that you
can do in your own local communities so
it's yeah it's going to probably be not
a great time for for going away but
um I hope everyone has a question that's
a lovely Easter with with France friends
family or whatever else you want to do
but a good time perhaps to do some
spring cleaning or you or you could stay
at home on the sofa and watch Sky and
use breakfast on Easter Sunday with me a
quick look at the front page of the
Daily Star Allison the Italian Prime
Minister following the French and
demanding a ban on English words do you
agree see or no I I like that the bottom
Bell it says that there's an argument
over here to say is it bruschetta or
bruschetta
um tamales and toasted or no
color whatever you want
um I do I do think it's it's hilarious
but it does remind me of you know when
people go on holiday and they make very
very poor attempts to try and pronounce
words with a local accent and I wouldn't
blame any country if we want to put a
ban on that Mary a quick thought from
you is it bruschetta or bruschetta
I guess I would say bruschetta but um no
Italian specialist I do go on holiday at
least once a year to Italy because I
love it and I think the Italians love
the Brits and that's the most important
thing